all right Ki yes hi Ki where are you
from originally where' you grow up I
grew up in Northwest Indiana a very
small town called Griffith 2 miles by
two
miles tell tell me about your childhood
growing up um I had both parents in the
home it was a fairly okay childhood um I
had my dad in the home but my theory is
he stopped paying attention to me when I
got a mind of my own um so him and I
haven't been close my whole life we are
now um but my mom is my rock my absolute
best friend and soulmate you're close to
your mom oh yeah most definitely she's
my best friend what was what what would
you say is the the roughest part of your
childhood the roughest part of my
childhood was probably watching my
parents get into some legal trouble um
when I was very young uh I didn't even
find out what they did until I was 15 or
16 but the house got raided and I
watched my parents get taken away so
what were they
doing um they were drug dealers so but
everybody's clean and silver now and
doing really well good how far did you
go to school oh I I graduated I
graduated from my local high school in
Griffith but what kind of kid were you
in high
school I was a good kid until I turned
16 and then I
started smoking weeds skipping school
doing drugs
drinking um I actually got expelled
December of my senior year uh for having
Xanax on me and my mom had called the
school and told them so I did get
arrested um I just turned 18 at 18 um
for having drugs at school and then I I
kind of continued to get arrested on and
off and crash multiple vehicles on drugs
until I turned 21 when I got clean for
good for good for good good for you yeah
been 12 years that's great thanks and
where's your life gone since then it's
better now I mean I I'm a mom I have two
children I'm a provisional Community
Association manager for HOAs um I live
in Reno I just have the best boyfriend I
could ever ask for
so it's been different but where I'm at
right
now is good what what what have you been
through between the boyfriend and uh
moving or leaving high school so I moved
to Reno with a man that I had known in
person for just a month or so um I met
him through the company I was working
for
uh he ended up not being the nicest man
ever but I followed him to Reno um and I
was with him for almost a
decade but uh I probably wasn't the best
wife to
him uh so we got divorced in July
of 2020 I believe you were married how
many years we were
married six together almost
10 yeah you guys had
problems um yes we both had our own sets
of problems um like I mentioned he
wasn't very kind uh so he did lay hands
on me um be very rude to me make
terrible comments call me names put me
down um but then
I was on
Unfaithful a few times and ended up uh
mothering children from those
men on my husband um so you were married
to your husband but you were having
children with other men I
was I was um and he raised them as his
own and knew them to be his own until
the
divorce how did that news come out my
lawyer had to use language in the in
what we wanted
to kind of make it a point to say that
like he may not be the dad you know like
I don't even remember what word she used
but it was a word that kind of made his
lawyer be
like we should probably do a DNA test on
these
children and he did cuz you're looking
to keep it
quiet I wouldn't say that to collect
child support no oh no the the div
divorce agreement said no child support
on either side we were both making the
same amount of money so to this day
neither of us pays child support um but
no he got them I I didn't I didn't want
to necessarily keep it quiet I didn't
want to break his heart is what it
is um no matter how mean he was to me I
don't use that as an excuse for what I
did because there's not an excuse you
know and I uh I carry a lot of guilt
with me about it and I got my babies I
mean they're the they're the greatest
things in the whole world but how how
did he find out he did the paternity
test and the paternity test came back he
was 99% like not the
father and he called me and he was like
do you want to get in front of this I
said get in front of what what do you
mean and about an hour later he had
posted publicly on Facebook
that he was not the father of the
children how many kids two how old were
they five at the time four and two 4 and
two and they still know him to be their
only
father and he
still treats them as if he's the only
father so he's still in their lives oh
yeah it's very nice of him if that's
what you want to call it
I call it control but nice is not a word
that people often use for this
man anything he can do to
not essentially let go of me and to kind
of continue to control my life is what I
think to be the reason he sees them once
a week takes them every other weekend
maybe not even the whole
weekend so it's an ugly divorce it was
ugly it went on for about seven or eight
months which I know is not long in most
divorces but I thought it was going to
be a cut and dry quick thing I didn't
think he was going to fight me on it I I
thought he didn't like me this whole
time but here we are so he did fight me
on pretty much everything I asked for um
the divorce ended pretty equal nobody
got anything
crazy um 50/50 with the kids until he
ended up
unhoused
um but yeah he's still present he still
shows up to parent teacher conferences
he coached my son's baseball team last
summer so he's still as involved as he
wants to
be and you you would prefer that was not
the case
or I unfortunately I he doesn't like to
pick
this is going to sound bad about me but
he doesn't like to pick the best women
um and I do feel that one day there will
come a woman who doesn't necessarily
want him to raise children who aren't
his um I hope that doesn't
happen but if that does happen I will
have wished he had made the move sooner
did you premeditate this or just you all
of a sudden you found out you were
pregnant by somebody you were cheating
with oh no it was definitely not
premeditated but
we weren't using
protection um so it was premeditated I
didn't say like I'm going to have sex
with this man to have a baby you know
but I mean I guess there was nothing
done to prevent
it um and the first man that I had the
affair with was is now is now my
boyfriend um the father of my first
child my son and uh he was my husband's
assistant
manager at the time this gets messy it's
very yeah yeah it's very messy so my
husband brought my ex-husband brought
him onto the team where he was working
and my ex-husband always made his
assistant managers like his best friend
so he started bringing this guy around
and I made I made the first move of
course
um and I feel like I just sensed his
kindness I mean still to this day this
this man that I'm with is the kindest
most patient man I've ever met so I
think I felt that kindness from him
which I wasn't getting from my husband
at the
time um so I don't even know how it
started Beyond me just touching his hand
when we were smoking
joints but one day he came over my house
without my ex-husband there
and you know what happened next and we
only saw each other once a week to do
this because of how my schedule my
ex-husband's schedule and his schedule
matched up so every Wednesday I saw him
we had sex he watched me get ready for
work and then he'd go work for my my
ex-husband yeah so that's how that one
started and again I mean my son is just
the best human ever so I don't regret it
and I'm with him now and he's just my
absolute soulmate and I haven't cheated
on
him but the second Affair who the man is
the father of my daughter he actually
worked with me this time he was my
maintenance guy at my leasing
job and again just another kind man who
was nice to
me and I would see him a lot more CU we
work together so we would take our
lunches together um and have sex
then and uh when I found out I was
pregnant with my
son we were 100% sure it was my
husband's even though I was having an
affair because I don't know I just
always felt like I could sense when I
got pregnant which obviously isn't right
but I just felt it so we were so sure so
sure and then he came out looking like
my boyfriend now spitting image um so
there were some questions at the
beginning
there um but still you have to be really
sure about that to
uh confront your wife you know you got
to be real sure so he didn't people
question what he looked like to him and
he just said
no um and then with my daughter she's
Hispanic um so she came out a little
more tan than the both of us um um and
just as she grew up just kept that tan
skin and still she looks so much like me
he was just like yep she looks like my
wife and now she looks like her dad
which is terrifying um but again I love
her crazy ass too but do you have
regrets about anything you've
done I wouldn't say regrets because I
got my babies so I definitely am not
going to say that I reget
it I wish I would have gone about it
differently maybe or maybe picked a
second different baby daddy I don't know
cuz I didn't even want to I didn't even
think he was going to be my baby daddy
and here we are with three baby daddies
and two kids is what I joke
about so yeah it's been wild emotionally
what what is I'd say yeah emot you're
putting other people through emotions
that they
never yeah his ex's family cut him off
once he decided to claim the children
they didn't like that and they
threatened to sue me with fraud because
of what they had bought in the children
and then um I mean of course I took away
my ex-husband's whole life in one swift
you know housewife
kids so there's I think the craziest
part is just the guilt that I always
feel like every day and if I think about
it I cry um and I've gotten called a lot
of names and I get it I do but it's like
I've called myself those names more than
anybody else has you're higher on
yourself than everyone else absolutely
and I mean and my mom used to say the
people who love you love you like
they're not going to judge you and I
know that I mean everybody who loves me
has been so supportive and so amazing
but I judge me
was there was there a little bit of
Revenge or satisfaction in in what you
did no I mean my babies's I guess would
be the satisfaction but no I mean it
didn't even make me feel better cuz he
was never any nicer to me he still
treated me like crap you know and still
no matter how he treated me I still feel
like this
about what I did to him cuz it sucks I
literally I ripped his whole life away
and one talk yeah that would be a
horrible thing to go with her you know
and it's like I didn't come out
unscathed I mean he was mean the whole
process
but my life wasn't
ruined my whole life wasn't taken away
from me so I always feel worse about
what I did to him than anything than
anything that's what gets me every
day
what was the hardest part of the
marriage for you my treatment the way I
was treated and the fact that my dad was
never very kind to my mom and I won't
again I won't use that as an excuse but
so therefore I feel like I kind of let
men treat me terribly my whole life I
mean now I'm a badass and I'm like
I'll rock your but I let men treat
me bad my whole life I always joke that
I grew around grew up around mean men my
whole life so now I know how to handle
them and uh what the final straw was for
me with my ex was he physically
assaulted me in front of the children
and uh my son had to use a plastic sword
to like hit his dad and get him off me
and my son's five now this
was a year and a half two years ago and
uh he still brings it up he's still
talks to me about it so I think the
hardest part was allowing was the
treatment and allowing my children to
see the way I was treated cuz they
hadn't watched me get good love the
first four or five years of their
life um so that was the hardest part
because I don't want my daughter to do
what I did you know I want both my kids
to be treated respectfully and kindly
and they see that now
but but your relationship ship with your
father was tumult tumultous Tous yeah
um I was a daddy's girl until I could
form my own opinions I I say um once
everything daddy said wasn't right and
wasn't true that's kind of when
he I don't want to say didn't
care he just stopped being so present in
my life
um and he he would make up comments
about my weight and I got a eating dis
you know just he wasn't a nice man
that's and I know that's where I get
wanting kindness so bad he was never a
nice man um but now he's older I mean
and I gave him the boy he always wanted
so he's
Kinder
um but I still can't cry in front of him
tears are a big trigger for him and now
tears are a trigger for me when my kids
cry even though I cry every day when my
kids cry I lose I just can't handle
listening to someone cry even myself
it's but like I said now we're good I
mean I see him three four times a year
he loves my kids to death um and my
stepmom's great I didn't like her my
whole life but now that I'm older I can
see that she was just doing what was
best for everyone
involved my dad
mainly he's a better person because of
her for
sure what are you proudest of in your
life
surviving just being able to wake up
this morning and come here you know
um I had a couple suicide attempts you
know just because life is wild and when
you're a addict sometimes that's you
know that's all you can see as an
escape um but I survived it so obviously
I'm supposed to be here or
whatever um and now I know it's because
I was put on this Earth to be a mom to
my children but you never know what your
purpose is until you get there and then
you're still unsure you know so I say
I'm alive for my
kids cuz they're just they're the best
people I've ever met are are the
children confused about who their
fathers are they no because they've only
known him they've only known my ex as
their father no but but the the son who
is actually your boyfriend is the actual
father but your ex-husband is his
original father yes that's confusing for
him
right I feel like children are smarter
than we think they are so I believe that
my son can just almost feel it you know
um they look identical they're twins
bodybuild face hair everything just the
same person in different bodies and I
know he's going to start asking
questions probably here soon because he
knows they look alike and you know
Austin's so amazing to him and just so
kind and patient even with my crazy
daughter so I feel like he feels
something you know he he knows what now
he knows what good love looks like and I
do believe he'll start asking
questions um and a part of me thinks
he'll be relieved to find out but no
child will either will even find out
until my ex and I both decide that it's
time so your son is older than your
daughter he is he's five so you had the
relationship with your boyfriend and
then you yeah had another relationship I
did so I had a relationship with my
boyfriend about six years ago and then
once I got pregnant we actually kind of
stopped communicating he moved away and
then I had the baby and he brought his
girlfriend to my
house to meet unknowingly our child um
me and my ex-husband and I wasn't super
kind to her um because I think maybe I
knew and I didn't like the guy that I
had loved at one point bringing another
woman in my house even though I was
living with another
man um so he did meet kot right when he
was born and then he kind of disappeared
again when he was still living out of
town and uh he was still following me on
social medias which I didn't know and my
ex was like you know he's still looking
at my stories and I'm like if he's
looking at your stories he's looking at
my stories and so that's how I
reconnected with him once the divorce
happened was I just reached out to him
on social media you're trouble I'm not
anymore I used to be what's
changed I'm madly in love with him and
he's kind and patient and everything I
could have ever imagined the father of
my children to
be and he's one of those guys that when
you get him you can't let him go cuz
someone else will get him and then
you're going to be mad he's just the
greatest human just
amazing so I mean I I kind of knew up
until him and I got back together that
he was always my
soulmate and he is I do believe that to
this
day and here he is just in my life
again so I'm happy and I'm not trouble
anymore I'm good to him for the most
part you sure yes I'm
positive I do I can't mess this one up
my ex-husband sucked but this one's a
good one
so I won't mess this one
up after going through all of this what
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in all of
this to find the right one for you if
you stay 10 years in a marriage that
isn't the right one then you're just
going to live miserably your whole life
or end up doing what I did and I feel
like if you're truly happy and if they
treat you how you deserve to be treated
and you know you treat them the
same I I feel like that's the biggest
thing is just finding the right
one and I was very young and newly clean
when I had met my ex-husband so I was in
a very vulnerable state and so now being
clean I was
clean 5 months when I met him now being
clean 12 years and building up my
backbone again and becoming the person I
was always supposed to be um really
opened up the doors for me to finally be
able and be able to be in a healthy
relationship and this is the healthiest
one I've ever been in it's
weird feels funny but we're doing it I
hope it lasts I do too for the kids sake
I do too all right Kira thank you so
much for sharing your story mark thanks
for having me I you guys lots of luck
thank you thank you thank
you